and right into that Fox News Alert the
text of the newest spending proposal
from the Senate has finally been made
public it's kind of hard to read like
that so let's take a look at some of the
key border Provisions it mandates a
shutdown if the daily average of
encounters hits 5,000 it ends the Biden
administration's use of Catch and
Release and creates a new border
emergency Authority where the president
can just shut her
down all right it's 8 billion in
spending it also includes 60 billion
plus to support Ukraine 14 billion for
assistance to Israel Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer says a vote could
come as soon as 48 hours from now but
GOP lawmakers are arguing otherwise we
have Team coverage we have meline Rivera
she's in Washington but first we're
going to go to Lawrence he's at the big
board and he's going to break down the
bill for us hey Lawrence hey good
morning family so if you were looking at
your phone right before the Grammy
Awards you got that Fox News Alert that
the the text was going to be released
let's go into some of the five things
that are in the Bill concessions from
both the Democrats and Republicans first
you go to no amnesty for anyone already
here apparently this was a big deal for
the Democrats they wanted amnesty
especially when it came down to some of
those dreamers but that is not in the
bill then you got the 50,000 uh new
visas per year for five years
Republicans did not want to give in on
this uh but democ rats it was a big
issue for them 50,000 that'll total to
about
250,000 uh in in that 5year period Then
you got the $650 million to build the
wall never did I think you'll see a
Democrat support that but apparently uh
because of this bipartisan compromise uh
they're going to support that and then
this is a big takeaway as well the
increased ice funds and detention
capacity up to
$50,000 and then the point of contention
if you remember uh it was some back and
forth we had some leaks going on they
said that this was not in the bill but
apparently it is the shutdown Authority
after 5,000 uh encounters a day
Apparently after uh you get that 35,000
a week but apparently when there's 5,000
people that have cross the border
there's an automatic shutdown we're
going to be breaking it down all morning
I'm Steve duy I'm Brian killme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis